Today I'm speaking with Dr.
Doug Fridsma.
Doug is an internal
medicine physician and
also has a PhD in
Biomedical Informatics from Stanford.
Starting in 2009, he joined the Office
of the National Coordinator for
Health IT, was there for
some five years and
is now the President of the American
Medical Informatics Association.
So, Doug, thank you for
being here with me today.
>> Thank you, I'm delighted to be here.
>> So you were there from
the beginning of high tech,
effectively through the end,
although ONC is still in operation.
>From my point of view you
guys accomplish a great deal.
More maybe than I would have imagined,
that many people would have imagined.
So can you tell us what you
feel the high points and
the major accomplishments were?
>> Well I think if you take a look
at the adoption of electronic health
records in a country.
When we started in 2009 there was about
a 17% adoption of electronic health
records.
Just last year it's at least larger
medical centers, It's close to 80, 90%.
And even among the physicians
in the smaller practices,
it's probably in the range of 60 to 70%.
So in the course of 5 years we took
20% of the largest GDP in the world.
And we convert it essentially
from a paper-based system to
an electronic system.
And I think It's not the end.
That actually is now the beginning
as we begin to figure out how to
connect the pieces and how we can refine
and make them better for the doctors and
patients that use them.
>> So, as I speak about things today,
I say that
the first big challenge was adoption,
and that has been largely overcome, not
entirely overcome And predictably, the
next big challenge is interoperability.
And as you read about physician
frustrations with EMRs,
the difficulty of getting these systems
to talk to each other is usually
high on their list,
if not at the top of their lists.
So, where do you feel we are on that and
what does your crystal ball tell us?
>> Well, I think interoperability
is probably the next big challenge.
I think there are issues in usability.
I think there are issues in safety and
security.
All of those things,
I think, are going to be important
now that we've got adoption.
But, when it comes to
interoperability,the thing that is so
critical is to really define
what it is that you want to do.
So when somebody complains that
their systems are not interoperable,
my first question to them is well
what were you trying to accomplish?
The definition of interoperability
is about the ability to exchange
information, and then the ability to use
the information that's been exchanged,
so you can't separate interoperability
from the thing you want to do.
We think sometimes that interoperability
is this green pasture that we're
eventually going to get to.
This state of being that
everything is going to work.
But in fact, interoperability
is one of those things that's
based on the things you want to do.
It's incremental.
It's iterative, and we will never
probably ever get there entirely
because there will always do a new
thing that we want to do for
which the capability doesn't exist.
>> So this course in the informatics
world in general there's a lot
of excitement about FHIR, as maybe
the solution to interoperabilities.
What are your views on that?
And do you see FHIR as the sort of
tool that can evolve as people's
requirements become more
sophisticated over time?
>> So, the great thing about
FHIR is it solves a problem.
And when you've got a standard, or
if you've got a technology that solves
a problem people are going to
use it because it helps them.
A lot of times we create
standards in committees and
have the expectation that if we
build it, people will then use it.
And we've got that wrong.
What we need to do is
find the problems for
which we can develop standards
that solve those solutions.
HL7, which is sort of the place
that FHIR has developed,
it had their first set of standards
really to help create interoperability
within the enterprise, and
many of the vendors adopted it,
it was wildly successful, it was able to
connect all of the pharmacy systems to
the laboratory systems and things,
using those kinds of messages.
FHIR stands to transform the same
thing between enterprises, and
because it's aimed at
the implementer and
geared towards the person who's
actually going to have to use it.
It's simple, it's easy to use,
it uses the best technologies
that are out there.
And a standard isn't a standard because
you say it is, it's a standard because
people use it, and this is a standard
that people actually are using, so
I think it's going to
have tremendous impact.
So shifting gears a bit,
we've emphasized in this course,
and are emphasizing, the chronic disease
patient who's got multiple problems and
multiple doctors.
There's an obvious need for
information sharing there, and
the role that the patient might and
arguably should play in their own care.
As you look out to the future,
how do you see the patient fitting into
the whole spectrum of informatics and
where the data is stored and
how the data is accessed?
>> You know,
you can take a look at what's happened
in other parts of a person's life,
an individual's life, to get a sense for
what may be happening in healthcare.
So, it used to be that
to get a airline ticket,
you had to call up a travel
agent who would then
access this system that you had no
way of knowing what was in there.
Now, all of those things are available
for individuals and they can make
their own hotel reservations,
and their own plane tickets.
I think the EHRs right now
are kind of in that same rule.
You go there, there's information in
there that the doctor tells you about,
and then you'll use that
information in your healthcare.
As we begin to open that up, not only
in the terms of having access for
the patients, but for the patients
to put their information into it.
You suddenly have one more information,
and you empower the patient to have
a whole lot more knowledge
about what's going on.
So, to me, it's not a matter of if,
it's a matter of when.
Because the things that are happening in
the rest of society are going to begin
to impact healthcare
in a substantive way.
And as it becomes easier and cheaper for
patients to have access to their own
information, that's going to happen.
>> So if adoption was the first big
challenge, and interoperability is
the second, and the least in my view of
the world, the third is the analytics.
Where do you think we
are in analytics and
where do you think we're going to
go in the next few years.
>> I think, again, there's a lot of good
work that's been done in bioinformatics.
I think we're starting
to see it in other
areas in which people are beginning
to aggregate that data.
Part of the challenge that we have in
health care is that not only do we have
knowledge about healthcare and
medicine and the associations there.
We need to be able to apply
that to the data that we see.
And so, it isn't simple
mathematical relationships.
It isn't necessarily,
simple associations.
But there's sort of a deep
understanding of medicine and
care delivery,
that's embedded in the data there.
So, it's an exciting
time because as more and
more of this data becomes available,
we're going to be able to apply
those informatics techniques to
be able to extract information.
But to do it in a way that is
understanding of how
the cure is delivered.
And if we can leverage the best that's
happening in the engineering field and
computer science and
marry that with what we understand
about healthcare delivery.
I think we're going to
make some good progress.
Are we there yet?
No.
I think there's still a lot
that needs to be done.
We're seeing some areas of excellence,
sort of centers that are doing some
of that, hospitals like Geisinger and
Kaiser and others that
are doing some analytic work.
But I only see this accelerating
at an incredibly rapid pace.
Storage and the movement of the data
is becoming less and less expensive.
And as a result I think more and
more analytics will be applied.
>> Is the lack of structure
in a great deal of medical
record information a barrier to that?
Do we need to keep pushing toward
a goal that many of us had years and
years ago of everything
being structured,
or Are we okay with where we are at,
in terms of nature of the data?
>> I actually think that you need
structure when you need to make
decisions or help for an individual
patient, or a small group of patients.
It's difficult to determine
a drug-drug interaction through our
data analytics on a single patient.
So you need to be able to categorize
that stuff so that rules can fire and
alerts can be sent.
But when you start to have
hundreds of millions of patients.
I think the need for
structure actually goes down,
even technologies like IBM Watson
unstructures structured data to be
able to do the analytics that they do.
So, I think we need to be very
comfortable with the ability to have
unstructured data.
Part of the challenge that we're going
to have is that if what we do is we
require structure as a barrier
to exchange of information.
We're going to sell ourselves short
in our ability to do analytics.
We need to get all the data out there so
that we could apply those analytics.
>> If you could rewind the clock and
spend your five years at
ONC all over again, what are one or
two things you would do differently?
>> You know, it was a remarkable time
to be in the federal government,
with the passage of the HITECH Act, and
just the excitement that was going on.
Obviously if all of the standards
had been baled, and had been ready.
That we could have just picked them
off the shelf and put them out there.
That would have made
our job a lot easier.
What we need is going to be a portfolio.
We have the beginnings of a portfolio.
I think we did a grand experiment that
was different than any other country in
terms of how we tried to
approach this problem.
We didn't engineer it from the top down,
we created the building blocks and
allowed the market to
sort of drive that.
Now, it's resulted in some innovative
companies sort of getting lost.
I wish there was a way that we could
have created a playing field that
allowed everybody to equally compete.
But sometimes that's hard, and
when you use a market-driven approach,
there are some Winners and
losers in all of that.
The challenge that we
have I think is that,
as we have all of these
products out there,
we've reached a level of saturation and
adoption in the market place.
We're going to start to
see some consolidation.
What's important is that we
don't lose that innovative and
entrepreneurial edge as that happens.
And I think things like FHIR, that
produce the ability to create apps and
to create other kinds of
functionality are going to be
really important as we go into that next
level, where we take where we have now,
and we begin to refine it and
add the analytics that we need.
>> The Jason report essentially paints
a picture of EHRs as a database.
And most of end-user work,
particularly in the physicians and
patients, is done through
apps that access data,from
that database using FHIR,and also,
of course, can add data to it.
Is that the world of
the future that you see?
>> I think increasingly the electronic
health record is going to be a data
store in the sky.
I think that patients
are going to be the principle
health information exchange,
in that they'll be the hub for
all this information that's
going to be exchanged.
I hope that at the end, all of this
technology doesn't create additional
barriers for patients, but makes them
first order participants in their care.
I think when that happens,
we are actually going to be able
to have tremendous innovation.
Perhaps the biggest underutilized
innovative force in medicine
is the patient.
And I think their needs are going to
probably drive more innovation that
anything we could ever think of and
think about with regard to
physicians and nurses and others who
are using the electronic health worker.
>> So the exercise that students in
this course are going through, and
it aims to learn FHIR and
develop fire apps
toward the future world where
that's the primary vehicle for
use by physicians and patients
makes sense to you, it sounds like.
>> Yeah, it does.
I think that's a great approach
to kind of set the stage.
I mean, if you want to know what
the future is, you have to be there and
try to invent it.
>> Well, great.
Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> For being with me here today.